you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trompe d'opa sur un jeu parce que j'ai
quelques informations à vous donner je
vais vous faire un cours jt très
intéressant de les voir
l'actualité en ce vendredi c'est pas
drôle faut arrêter les blacks où elles
sont nulles lucas mais sérieusement je
prends des vacances voilà j'aime prendre
huit jours de vacances à compter
d'aujourd'hui donc il n'y aura pas de
vidéo pendant huit jours au magot est ce
que vous allez sur fibres où allez vous
succombez à l'apocalypse a way to monde
s'en fout on va rater faire genre en
fait au moment où vous voyez cette vidéo
je suis déjà en vacances donc lucas si
tu regarde ta propre vidéo sachka à ce
moment là tu es a hâte de partir trop la
bâche
ça va permettre de sortir un peu la tête
de youtube des troupes de ré attaquer la
rentrée avec beaucoup plus d'envié que
si j'avais vraiment pas fait de pause
pendant les vacances de voir aussi un
peu la famille enfin voilà de prendre
soin de ses proches finalement ouais je
sais c'est très mignon ça c'est beaucoup
moins sexy d'ailleurs j'ai quelques
idées de trucs cool qu'on va pouvoir se
faire à la rentrée ça va être super
sympa voilà je voulais juste vous
prévenir de ce trou de vidéos que soi
n'est pas en position foetale en pensant
que je me suis fait croquer par une
[ __ ] d' énormes araignées qui campe
est juste là il ya quelques semaines
elle aurait plus ma vallée l'agent
ramblas à gourin oh la vache folle à
bélouve est il au lavage
voilà totalement normal cyr ce fameux
trou écoute et j'espère en tout cas que
vous vous passer de très bonnes vacances
que vous décompresser bien vous amuser
au soleil que vous faites des rencontre
ou que vous restez sur l'ordi à longueur
de journée à xp votre perso sur world of
warcraft c'est pas mal aussi à jouer les
faits a gelé fait j'étais heureux à
escou parents des bases sûres sur world
of war on s'en fout ça me faire du bien
vous c'est à vous faire du bien depuis
voir ma gueule sur youtube auxerre à 8
derrière c'est du tout bénef pour tout
le monde là j'espère que vous qui fait
bien mais en vacances et l'important
vraiment et puis que vous partez ou pas
et bien profiter de vos grasses matinées
profiter de de faire plein de trucs que
vous pourriez pas faire parce que vous
n'avez pas le temps habituellement dans
le quotidien
je donne de leçon de vie alors j'ai 19
ans il est vrai bon voilà 50 ans je
devrais des leçons de d'existence
j'en profite aussi une fois de plus on
vous dira merci comme habitude de
regarder les vidéos de suivre de
contribuer pta est maintenant des gens
font des jeux pour nous c'est juste
incroyable j'ai pas je veux ça me ça me
choque ça m'étonne ça m'etonne je
regrette cette blague c'est juste une
aventure de dingue
voilà je me suis cassé le doigt et je
suis d'ailleurs un peu pressé de vous
revoir vos squeeze gaming show déjà et
ensuite peut-être à la à la paris games
week sûrement et aussi à la vidéo city
est aussi chez moi et chez toi merci
voilà y'a rien de plus à dire on se
retrouve très vite du coup dans une
prochaine vidéo vous en faites pas neuf
jours huit jours sept jours c'est quoi
dans une vie
indique mon mal et on part en
philosophie j'ai eu 7 sur 20 en philo au
bac ok le sujet c'était sommes-nous
redevable envers l'état ou un truc du
genre
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo ce retour
très bientôt dans une prochaine je vous
souhaite de très bonnes vacances
je me souhaite aussi de très bonnes
vacances merci d'avoir regardé chat ou
le portez vous bien pis
oh
je suis love de vous